Grazie
Buonasera a tutti
Surface è una parola a me molto cara e
inglese significa superficie
pensate che cos'è una superficie Beh in
fondo è quell'elemento di separazione
Ciò che distingue me dal mondo esterno e
quell'elemento che delimita e definisce
due corpi ogni giorno abbiamo a che fare
con diverse superfici grazie al tatto e
immaginate Quante proprietà siamo in
grado di riuscire a percepire attraverso
il contatto l'interazione con le
superfici proprietà come è caldo è
freddo e liscio e rugoso e colorato e
appiccicoso e sdrucciolevole è morbido e
duro
e proprio
questa questa parola che porto con me
durante la mia attività di ricerca
pensate anche ai vostri sentimenti cosa
sarebbe un bacio o un abbraccio senza
l'incontro tra due superfici
la parola trilogia indica la scienza che
studia l'interazione tra le superfici In
particolare quando Queste sono in
movimento relativo tra di loro venne dal
greco tribos più logos vuol dire
letteralmente sarebbe lo studio dello
sfregamento lo studio dell'attrito oggi
la trilogia è una scienza piuttosto
complessa ha a che fare con una miriade
di applicazioni che utilizziamo tutti i
giorni la tipologia Studia per esempio
l'aderenza tra lo pneumatico della
vostra vettura e la strada in condizioni
di asciutto o di bagnato la trilogia si
occupa di assicurare la tenuta tra il
gommino dello stantuffo della siringa e
la sua camicia la trilogia si occupa di
studiare come lo scorrere di un archetto
sulle quattro corde di un violino
produce quella fantastica melodia che
tutti quanti che ha tutti i piani quanti
piace ascoltare ma la trilogia Indaga
anche Quali sono le proprietà delle
superfici delle foglie di loto tali che
le rendono autopulenti e la tipologia
studia anche questo studia anche come i
nostri polpastrelli interagiscono con
gli onnipresente touchscreen pensate una
ricerca recente ha mostrato che
interagiamo con lo schermo del nostro
smartphone per più di 2.600 volte al
giorno
che la trilogia fosse una scienza
meritevole di studio avevano capito già
le popolazioni antiche quello che vedete
qui è la ricostruzione di un affresco è
stato ritrovato nella tomba di un
governatore Egizio deotiotep risale al
1900 avanti Cristo raffigura la scena di
172 lavoratori che vedete inbracano
delle funi e trasportano tra questo
questi funi un enorme slitte su questa
slitta Una statua è alta circa 6,8 metri
ed ha un peso stimato di circa 58
tonnellate Ma andiamo ad ingrandire
davanti alla slitta lì c'è un
inserviente con un otre sembra
gettare un fluido proprio davanti alla
slitta pare sia acqua e la prima
testimonianza storica giunta fino a noi
3.900 anni dopo di lubrificazione di due
superfici pensate gli storici hanno
dimostrato che mediante questa tecnica
era possibile quasi dimezzare la forza
di traino sicché ogni singolo individuo
era in grado di trasportare fino a 350
kg
ma i primi esperimenti sistematici
sull'attrito sono stati svolti da lui lo
conoscete tutti e Leonardo da Vinci e
forse il più eclettico degli scienziati
che l'Italia e forse il mondo intero
abbia mai conosciuto artista scultore
pittore e lui nel 1400 compila i suoi
codici tra questi codici il codice
arundell conservato oggi presso la
British Library a Londra inizialmente si
guarda questi bozzetti si ritiene siano
scarabocchi vengono messi da parte non
vengono studiati poi un ricercatore un
ricercatore dell'università di Cambridge
Li riprende di studi a minuziosamente il
codice a roundell e scopre che questi
bozzetti questi che sembravano essere
scarabocchi contengono In realtà i
bozzetti dei esperimenti sistematici che
Leonardo stava svolgendo per cercare di
carpire quali fossero le leggi che
governassero l'attrito vedete blocchi di
diverse dimensioni cavi puleggia e
collegati a pesi nel 1400 Leonardo il
primo uomo ad intuire che la forza
d'attrito non dipende dall'area di
contatto che la forza d'attrito dipende
dal peso dei corpi e per farci per fare
un esempio che abbiamo due corpi che
hanno lo stesso peso uno con una piccola
superficie di contatto uno con una
grande superficie di contatto questi
genera lo stesso attrito Questa è una
convinzione che ancora oggi noi portiamo
con noi nei nostri modelli che
utilizziamo a livello ingegneristico ma
fu sistematizzate ed elaborata solo
molto più tardi da due fisici francesi
Guglielmo a monton e Coulomb Charles
guglielm de Coulomb e Ma questo è
successo solo tra il 1600 e il 1700 300
anni dopo
oggi continuiamo ancora a fare
esperimenti a studiare l'attrito solo
che lo facciamo con degli strumenti
molto più sofisticati utilizziamo la
luce per andare a carpire Quali sono i
dettagli che costituiscono la superficie
utilizziamo i microscopi a forza atomica
delle puntine che hanno dimensioni
nanometriche vengono fatte scorrere
sulla superficie per carpirne il profili
utilizziamo elettroni spariamo elettroni
contro la superficie per andarne a
carpire le caratteristiche sub
nanometriche un attimo subnano metriche
vogliamo ricostruire una superficie
andando a guardare i dettagli che sono
più piccoli di un nanometro un nanometro
è pari a un milionesimo di millimetro un
nanometro e la dimensione di una
molecola di glucosio lo zucchero che
utilizziamo tutti una manometro e un
centesimo di un normale virus Ed è
proprio grazie a questi strumenti grazie
a questi microscopi che noi abbiamo
capito che tutto ciò che appare liscio e
rugoso Questa è una superficie l'abbiamo
acquisita con un ingrandimento pari a
700 perse la vedreste ad occhio nudo
sembrerebbe perfettamente liscia invece
Guardate a Scala micrometrica un micron
in un millesimo di millimetro e un
pullulare di picchi di Valli Di dettagli
di selle Ma la cosa più straordinaria è
che queste sono le superfici naturali
immaginate una roccia sferzata dalle
intemperie che si frattura Beh se
l'andiamo ad osservare queste superfici
sono fatte così alla scala giusta ma la
cosa più strabiliante è che se andassimo
a zoomare se andiamo ad ingrandire
ancora di più alla scala più che
sub micrometrica Beh troviamo ancora
nuova rugosità troviamo ancora su una
superficie che simile a se stessa ancora
irregolare con questa con questa con
questa particolare texture e questo tipo
di geometria ha un nome specifico si
chiama geometria frattale e L'ha
introdotta lui è un matematico polacco
che vedete qui benoitman del brot
durante un Ted talk in cui introduce
proprio la geometria frattale che poi è
stata utilizzata la computer Science un
po' Dovunque ma ci sono tanti esempi di
geometrie frattali e anche in natura
molti natura oggi voglio mostrarne uno è
un cavolfiore Sì è un classico
cavolfiore come è fatto Beh una grande
protuberanza con tante protuberanze
disposte un po' a spirale No ma un
attimo se andiamo a zoomare ad
ingrandire una di queste protuberanze
Beh cosa vediamo una protuberanza con
tante protuberanze disposte a spirale e
se zumassimo ancora ancora e ancora
ancora un cavolfiore ma scala più
piccola Beh questa è l'essenza e così
che sono fatte le superfici naturali
Ma qual è l'implicazione che porta con
sé il fatto che queste superfici anche a
Scala micrometrica siano così irregolari
Beh immaginiamo due corpi che ho
disegnato una sfera un piano
portiamolo in contatto Beh Le superfici
sono rugose ormai lo sapete anche voi i
primi punti a toccarsi sono solo questi
piccoli sono solo questi picchi l'aria
di contatto reale i punti in cui in
effetti corpi sono in contatto lì dove
si toccano dove c'è intimo contatto è
estremamente più piccola dell'area di
contatto nominale di quella che appare
pensate Se questo fosse un contatto
metallo metallo l'aria di contatto reale
non raggiungerebbe nemmeno l'uno per
cento dell'area di contatto nominale ed
è per questo che i carichi i pesi che
noi andiamo a scaricare su queste
superfici vanno a
caratterizzarsi su questi piccolissimi
punti si sviluppano delle pressioni mani
pressioni elevatissime che vanno a micro
saldare a creare delle vere e proprie
incollaggi giunzioni a livello
micrometrico e quindi quando applichiamo
una forza facciamo fatica a rompere
queste giunzioni signore e signori
Eccovi spiegato l'attrito ma c'è ancora
qualcosa di cui vorrei parlarvi e di
come la natura l'evoluzione abbiano
sviluppato delle superfici gerarchiche
con l'obiettivo di poter aderire anche
su queste superfici così regolari così
rugose e sapete insetti animali sono in
grado molto spesso di camminare sui muri
di correre a testa in giù Chissà se
provano vertigine probabilmente no ma
saltano corrono su pareti verticali
quando si tratta di correre super di
verticali di andare a testa in giù Beh
il protagonista indiscusso è certamente
lui il geco qual è il segreto del Geco
vi dico subito Vi preannuncio nessuna
colla nessun effetto ventosa andiamo a
guardare le sue zampette queste Questa è
la zampa di un geco alla Scala di un
centimetro è composta da 5 dita pensate
la zampetta di geco è in grado di
sostenere da sola circa 20 volte il suo
peso ma ormai avete capito Il segreto
ingrandire andiamo ad ingrandire uno di
una di queste dita compaiono tante
lamelle delle lamelle a Scala
millimetrica questa struttura così
regolare ma ecco ingegneri scienziati
non siamo contenti soprattutto se
sudiamo trilogia continuiamo ad
ingrandire e ingrandiamo ancora a Scala
micrometrica vedete queste sete sono
questi profili
longilinei sono però più sottili di un
vostro capello qui si parla di qualche
decina di micron quindi stiamo parlando
di un quinto circa di un vostro capello
e il bello è che possiamo ancora
ingrandire possiamo ingrandire andare a
guardare le punte Se guardiamo le punte
vediamo che ogni seta che un quinto del
vostro capello è suddivisa in migliaia
di spatole spatole che hanno la
dimensione di poche decine di nanometri
e così che la zampa del Geco è ricoperta
da milioni di terminazioni milioni di
terminazioni che Gli permettono di
andare in utilizzato intimo contatto con
la superficie anche quando questo è
molto rugosa e questo Il segreto del
geco e questo è il motivo per cui riesce
ad aderire su pareti anche verticali
perché a quella distanza andando in
intimo contatto con la superficie riesce
a sfruttare le forze di van der Waals
che sono delle forze aspecifiche che
naturalmente esistono tra le superfici e
che hanno anche una componente adesiva
noi semplicemente noi le percepiamo le
siamo troppo lontani per noi c'è la
rugosità Ma il geco ha questa struttura
gerarchica che è in grado di fare
Appunto questo queste grandissime
prestazioni e noi chiaramente ci
lasciamo ispirare dalla natura copiarla
molto spesso è difficile è troppo
complessa ma ci lasciamo ispirare quindi
oggi siamo in grado di produrre
artificialmente delle superfici
gerarchiche Questa è una superficie che
contiene Qualche migliaio di
pillar sono questi cilindretti hanno
scala micrometrica circa 30 Micron sono
circa la metà di un vostro capello
facciamo questo per sviluppare degli
adesivi reversibili adesivi che sono in
grado di attaccarsi e poi distaccarsi
hanno però un difetto sono lente un geco
è in grado di attaccare e staccare la
sua zampetta in solo in meno di 10
millisecondi queste superfici invece
sono lente ed è per questo che nel 2021
Proposto al Consiglio Europeo della
ricerca una via idea un'intuizione
quella di utilizzare delle Vibrazioni a
livello micrometrico molto rapide Quindi
con una frequenza dell'ordine del
chiloers e con un'ampiezza dell'Ordine
dei Micron per andare a regolare le
forze di adesione di queste superfici
microstrutturate
Questo potrebbe avere un impatto un
futuro nello sviluppo di nuove
tecnologie per esempio Parla adesivi che
è possibile comandare
attraverso queste micro vibrazioni per
esempio per realizzare dei micro robot
che potrebbero imitare appunto Jake gli
insetti e arrampicarsi sulle superfici
oppure per sviluppare dei gripper oppure
dei manipolatori per il robot Soffici
L'idea è stata finanziata È stata
finanziata ed è per questo che oggi Sono
il responsabile scientifico del
laboratorio di tribodinamica presso il
Politecnico di Bari il dipartimento di
problematica abbiamo acquisito
strumentazione di un livello tecnologico
estremamente avanzato la migliore
strumentazione al mondo siamo in grado
di produrre superfici con una precisione
di 200 nanometri possiamo produrre
artificialmente superfici che hanno una
precisione di un quinto di micron e
stiamo mettendo su anche un gruppo di
ricerca un gruppo di ricerca
internazionale fatto di giovani che
vengono da tutto il mondo e vi assicuro
che ricordo molto bene quel giorno era
il 20 dicembre 2021 ricordo benissimo
quelli mail e quelle mail in cui sai di
giocarti tutto e quella mail in cui sai
di giocarti la tua idea la tua proposta
progettuale il tuo finanziamento il tuo
laboratorio il tuo gruppo di ricerca e
con la mail in cui sai di giocarti un
milione e mezzo di euro forse una
carriera intera vi assicuro che non c'è
parola migliore per descriverla se non
vertigine Grazie
[Applauso]